let's go
hey guys merry here for Comic Con 2015 I
am here at the halo 5 guardians breakout
arena it's giant area where shooting
each other with darts representing halo
5 guardians it is so much fun i'm here
with james mono smith from 343
industries no tell me a little bit about
halo 5 guardians breakout arena and what
you guys are doing here what we have
here is we have a recreation of a halo 5
breakout arena from our multiplayer mode
we have a partnership with boom co which
make these women amazing blasters are
actually creating some awesome halo
blasters for retail the season and we
decide to give fans a little sample of
what it's like to do live action halo
multiplayer if you even got a needler
xin there so you're actually really
trying to recreate some live action
weaponry going on oh yeah we've got
Needlers we've got magnums we have a
covenant placer pistols we have actual
halo weaponry so it looks like you're
really real game anything in there that
we can expect to see in the actual halo
5 Guardians sure I mean this actually
this course was designed from one of our
multiplayer designers and producers it
mimics one of the courses will have one
of the mass
have been halo 5 Guardians the gameplay
is actually very similar once you get
tagging you're out you're out for the
game you wait for the next round the
last team standing wins well it was
aight sweaty gross mess in there but the
red team did come out victorious and i'm
proud to say that me and Justin hey Wald
were on it it's been a great start so
far to comic-con and we are stoked to
see what else is coming up and thanks so
much James for showing us that further
rest of your comic-con coverage stay
tuned to gamespot com